thank you
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story the children who film
attacks on other children for likes of
notoriety Sky News investigates the
disturbing Trend to gain attention on
social media I don't really like walking
around now where I know people from my
school are going to be
because they are ever pretty much
everyone in my school knows about it
and the Army agrees to extend the
ceasefire as thousands scramble to flee
the fighting those who've already
escaped tell us about their ordeal
th
the moments our correspondent came
across one of her family reaching safety
also this evening
police find a body in a reservoir as
they search for the fiancee of a
pregnant teacher found dead in Glasgow
the latest nurses strikes are curtailed
by a court as a judge rules next week's
walkout is unlawful this is the darkest
day in this dispute so far
documents released by Prince Harry
between the palace and News Group
newspapers appear to show Queen
Elizabeth was fully aware of phone
hacking and surveillance on the Royal
Family
[Music]
plus tributes after the death of Jerry
Springer the controversial American talk
show host whose show transformed daytime
TV
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages and I'll press
preview that is coming up from 10 30
tonight
[Music]
hello there very good evening to you Sky
News has discovered growing evidence of
bullies setting up violent attacks on
fellow pupils and videoing them so they
can be posted in private chat groups the
national bullying helpline says it's a
sickening and escalating problem where a
child is humiliated for online
entertainment but it warns schools and
the police are often too slow to realize
is happening and not robust enough when
they do find evidence of it our home
editor Jason Farrell has this special
report and a warning that some viewers
may find some of the images distressing
a schoolgirl dragged down by her hair
and punched on the ground
we've protected identities but another
girl while filming gets involved kicking
her in the face
dozens are watching and videoing an
ambush that everyone seemed to know was
about to happen just outside a school in
Rochdale
and the motive quite possibly the videos
themselves a moment of notoriety on
social media creating content to be
shared and laughed about in private
groups on Snapchat
courageously the 13 year old girl who
was attacked just before the Easter
holidays wants to speak about it she's
asked not to show her face
and how badly did they hurt you I had a
black eye my head every time I spoke her
um I couldn't laugh because my head hurt
I couldn't move my neck my back was sore
I have a scar on my knee that they cut
open
I don't really like walking around now
where I know people from my school are
going to be
because they are ever up pretty much
everyone in my school knows about it
yeah
so you think it's just random they just
pick a Target yeah the easy target
someone who's normally quiet somebody
who doesn't bother anybody they'll then
use that person as a Target to create
this online so content yeah Billy the
half-brother and legal guardian of the
girl who was attacked says this is
becoming a dangerous craze I don't
believe my sister has any long-running
rivalries within the school I believe
this was created solely for the content
of the internet it was just a random
attack so that people could post it
online and show off you think it is a
craze it is a crazier it's happening all
over the country the national bullying
helpline told Sky News this is indeed an
escalating and deeply troubling National
Trend do the children realize that this
is a criminal offense beating somebody
up the police and the schools have got
to take more action
for safeguarding reasons we've decided
not to name the school in Rochdale near
where the attack happened but parents
tell us there have been several similar
attacks just at this one school
here inside the premises a girl secretly
starts recording we've reduced the audio
to protect identities but a verbal
assault leads up to a physical one
oh
yeah
the school we're not naming told us it
takes its duty of care extremely
seriously and they respond robustly to
disclosures on student safety the
instance we've highlighted are subject
to ongoing inquiries
Sky News understands the attack on this
13 year old is now being investigated by
the police but the national bullying
helpline says schools and authorities
are failing to keep Pace with this
growing uk-wide problem Jason Farrell
Sky News
Sudan's Army has agreed to extend the
fragile ceasefire in the country as the
Scramble for people fleeing the fighting
to escape continues British Nationals
still stuck in Sudan have been told to
move now if they want to leave so far
nearly 900 have been flown to safety
tens of thousands of people have already
left the country in the past few days
with 16 000 alone crossing the border
into Egypt one of the routes out of
Sudan is by boat to the Jeddah Islamic
port in Saudi Arabia our Africa
correspondent usra El begier was there
when one boat reached safety and unknown
to her one of her relatives was on board
HMS dive comes into Vision
means protected encircled
just like those on board
it's just unbelievable the ship's slowly
pulling in you start to see people's
features you see the eagerness on their
faces to get to safety after 10 hours at
Sea finally just some Solace from what
has been the most horrifying time
Saudi Arabia has evacuated more people
from the violent chaos of Sudan than any
other country in the world
and as they approached at the shores
gratitude overflows how are you feeling
I'm glad for good friends in Saudi
Arabia today I am an American yeah
uh it was a long journey out of cartoon
lots of craziness happening but you know
what the the Sudanese people themselves
were beautiful people if it hadn't been
to the Sudanese people helping us at
each Journey each step of the way it was
absolutely beautiful and then to see our
friends and brothers in Saudi Arabia get
us here I'm particularly grateful
in the hundreds of people in person I'm
waiting yeah
they have been traveling in this steel
group of people trapped there can you
believe this one running out of water
children inside
so but then we we got the chance to be
here
is that it's a heaven
final moments of disarray before their
feet hit steady ground and as the crowd
parts
but that's my uncle
no
[Music]
panic
attack
[Music]
s
Saudi Arabia's Navy has been commended
for its rescue efforts how much
resources have you thrown Behind These
evacuation missions we
used all of our resources and we don't
feel really we feel happy about this
within fears or we feel heavy and we are
ready to provide whatever we can to
complete this operations do you see more
evacuation missions in the future to
help some of these people who are
stranded
as a number already we didn't have exact
figures but we are ready to verify the
company
around 2 500 people from 67 countries
have made it to safety here men and
women old and young out of the
devastation bet many still far from home
Sky News
Scottish police have found a body in the
search for the fiance of a pregnant
primary school teacher who was found
dead in Glasgow 35 year old morel
starrick was discovered in the early
hours of Tuesday morning she was 29
weeks pregnant detectives launched a
murder investigation and a search for
David Yates whose car was spotted at
mugdock Country Park our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillies reports and
there is some flash photography a
warning for you
she was the much loved primary school
teacher who devoted her life to Children
the mum to be murdered 29 weeks pregnant
[Music]
Morel stoddock and her fiance David
Yates were music fans she was killed and
there was a Manhunt to find him
they can confirm that sadly had unborn
baby did not survive
our thoughts are with mireille's family
and friends and along with everyone
affected by this tragedy
Burrell's remains were found here at
their family home in Glasgow on Tuesday
but this investigation took detectives
to Woodlands 10 miles away this vast
area the place where a car belonging to
Yates was discovered
this is an investigation involving
specialist officers these divers
entering the nearby Reservoir teams
trained to use this equipment for
complex inquiries
after what was time Scouting For Clues
came the discovery of a man's body in
these Waters remains thought to be David
Yates
at the school where morel worked a sense
of loss did you teach your kids yeah
and what would you like so lovely so
very lovable and friendly as you always
helps her children of the field they're
very very upset I most know she'd be
like not um she's treated the kids like
her own she picked him up she had made
them have confidence within themselves
the school's head teacher described
Morel as kind diligent talented and
considerate someone who made time for
everyone a fitting tribute as murder
detectives attempt to discover why her
life was cut so cruelly short Corner
Gillis Sky News Glasgow
a 48-hour strike planned by nurses in
England next Tuesday has been cut short
after a judge ruled that it was unlawful
the health directory Steve Barkley had
made the argument that a six-month
mandate for Action would expire the
Royal College of Nursing didn't contest
the case but the Union's general
secretary Pat Cullen insisted the nurses
remain Resolute despite the ruling
Skye's Health correspondent arches Joshi
has this report
looked defiant and confident but while
there was a strong union presence
outside the high court inside it was
nobody to argue the nurse's case
the High Court ruled the planned 48-hour
strike which starts on Sunday evening
could not extend into next Tuesday
because the RCN mandate will have
expired
the judge Mr Justice Linden said the
union had shown a high degree of
unreasonableness that the outcome was
inevitable and instead of grasping their
nettle and conceding it had forced the
case to course
the strike was called after nurses
rejected the government's payoffer
earlier this month this is the dorkest
day in this dispute so far
any government that would drag their
nursing staff through the courts they've
won their legal battle today but what
this has led to is they've lost nursing
and they've lost the public
the walkout will be the first to include
emergency departments cancer Awards and
Intensive Care staff like birds it has
made me more determined I think a
government that rather goes to court
with for the nurses instead of sitting
in a negotiation room called me out and
we this is serious this is just a group
of people that doesn't know how to
respectfully sit together and and search
for a solution but Bert and his
colleagues could still have the
government's offer imposed on them as
other unions continue to ballot members
ahead of talks next week the government
said it regretted taking this court
action but felt it was necessary to
protect patients the NHS estimates
nearly half a million appointments have
been delayed over the past five months
of industrial action by health workers
every day of strike has an impact on
patients it's outpatients appointments
canceled tests canceled operations
canceled and absolutely you know we
don't want to stop at the right to
strike but it has to be done in a legal
way the RCN says it will rebalot members
over future strike action it further
dates are announced the union now knows
to make sure they're not breaking the
law
oh she's Josh she's Sky News at London's
High Court
gambling firms will be forced to
introduce more safeguards to help
prevent people getting addicted as part
of the biggest reform and regulation of
the industry for two decades
affordability checks will be brought in
and it's also to be a stake limit for
online slot betting with greater
protection for people aged between 18
and 24 who are considered more
vulnerable but there's no change to the
rules over advertising and Sport which
has disappointed campaigners our
business correspondent gurpreet Darwin
reports
the odd bet here and there but for some
the consequences are grave it was a huge
win I had when I was 29 life-changing
money
um and unfortunately it led me into the
deep dark
despair of a gambling addiction I just
don't understand
in 2023
how this is still being allowed to
continue it's a bit like smoking 40 50
years ago policymakers have finally
taken action publishing a long-awaited
white paper that will crack down on a
thriving industry we need a new approach
that recognizes a flutter is one thing
unchecked Edition addiction is another
among the policies outlined are a
statutory Levy that will force gambling
companies to fund treatment of addicts
by the NHS new Financial checks for
gamblers who lose 125 pounds or more in
a month and even more rigorous checks
for those who lose a thousand pounds a
day and maximum Stakes for online slot
machines of two pounds for anyone aged
under 25 and 15 pounds for everyone else
for some it hasn't gone far enough with
tougher rules on Advertising noticeably
absent
but the industry said it was important
for the right balance to be struck we
pay 4.2 billion in tax and we have 22
and a half million customers who take
part in betting and gaming activities
regularly and on a monthly basis
what's important about this white paper
is that it's proportionate that it's
evidence-based and that it's balanced
but we will be working with government
to implement the changes that they have
put forward
this is the biggest overhaul of gambling
rules in over a decade and while the
measures have been broadly welcomed the
weight isn't over just yet many of these
policies will go out for further
consultation and with the current
backlog of legislative business in
Westminster that could mean further
delays it's very simple take a pencil
preferably a red one and go consultation
no consultation no consultation no
statutory instrument yes statuesmen yes
statues are done
the work isn't done and in the meantime
gambling companies in Britain will
continue to enjoy one of the most
loosely regulated markets in the world
gabrit narwan Sky News
private emails have been released by
Prince Harry between Buckingham Palace
and Senior Executives at newsgroup
newspapers which appear to show the late
Queen was fully aware of the extent of
the impact of phone hacking on the royal
family and that negotiations were taking
place the documents emerged on the final
day proceedings brought by a group of
celebrities including the Duke of Sussex
also in court today was the actor Hugh
Grant who claims the Sun newspaper
covered up crimes including ordering
burglaries of his home allegations
denied by the publisher here's our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock
Prince Harry hasn't made it to court but
we know he's followed proceedings
closely as he accuses the sun and the
News of the World of phone hacking other
senior Royals were targeted at the time
and to that Harry's released more
sensitive emails from the palace to the
paper's Executives Rebecca Brooks and
Robert Thompson they show how much the
late Queen was involved
in July 2017 Sally Osmond the Queen's
head of communications emails them
confidentially with the Queen's full
Authority and knowledge of the scale and
effect of hacking and surveillance on
her family
the family wants an apology
in December Sally emails about that
unfinished business I do hope that we
can reach an understanding that resets
the relationship she says adding the
queen is aware that we have spoken
but the palace hears nothing in March
2018 Sally emails I was somewhat
disappointed not to receive an
acknowledgment let alone a reply she
says frustrations increasing by the lack
of response or willingness to engage
Sally threatens legal action but there's
no movement and in May she emails the
growing concern our request is not being
taken seriously
but Prince Harry is serious with this
legal action along with the actor Hugh
Grant who alleges phone hacking blagging
and even burglaries to order they're
fighting for a trial with the tabloids
if it goes to trial that will be a a
significant departure from from Waters
up until now the norm for the royal
family uh not to go into the witness box
with Fanfare the rest of the family are
preparing for the coronation the king
presenting new military standards in
colors
and the prince and princess of Wales
dropping in on the brecon beacons it
feels a world away from Harry's court
case Williams settled but his brother
still has a long way to go Laura bundock
Sky News
a new report has warned history could
repeat itself and that the Metropolitan
Police have failed to learn the lessons
from the investigation into the serial
killer Stephen Paul's he drugged his
four victims and dumped their bodies
near his flat in barking in East London
between June 2014 and September 2015. a
report from his Majesty's inspectorate
of constabury concluded that if local
officers had investigated the first
death properly the other three men might
still be alive our correspondent Rachel
venables reports
four young gay men drugged assaulted and
murdered by a serial killer Stephen Paul
was free to kill again and again and
again because of a calamitous Litany of
failures by the Met police who didn't
think the deaths were suspicious now a
damning new report warns it could happen
again
his Majesty's inspectorative
constabulary found a number of areas
where the Met failed eight years ago and
have kept on failing in the
investigations of sudden deaths for not
enough training for the junior officers
who get called out a lack of supervision
over those officers unacceptable record
keeping and even a Reliance on luck to
identify links between deaths at a local
level if they get the basics wrong right
at the start the chances of categorizing
the death wrongly and therefore the
danger of something like Stephen Port
happened again goes up missing another
serial killer it's entirely possible
this report is clear that three of
Stephen port's four victims didn't have
to die if officers had only done the
basics of police work from the beginning
instead he kept on killing in the same
way even leaving two of the bodies in
the same location at this graveyard here
in parking but the police didn't connect
the dots and failed for far too long to
realize they were dealing with a serial
killer Jack was very loving caring life
and so have her family life and solve
everything and yeah everyone just misses
him dearly Jenny and Donna's brother
Jack was port's Final victim we've not
been able to go for Jack because all
we've ever done is after fire fire and
we're still fighting to this day for a
public inquiry we're still fighting for
justice we're still fighting for
somebody to stand up
and and shove accountability
the Met police say the deaths of Anthony
wargate Gabrielle cavari Daniel
Whitworth and Jack Taylor were a tragedy
and we're sincerely sorry we failed them
and their families while as the
inspection report acknowledges we have
worked hard since the murders to
understand what went wrong and improve
how we work it highlights more we need
to do
the victim's families were told in the
inquest two years ago that police
mistakes probably led to their loved
ones deaths but this latest report
brings home the agony of knowing how
little has changed in the last eight or
four years and they must be wondering
how many more murders could have been
missed in that time Rachel Venable's Sky
News
rail unions have announced more strikes
affecting the FA Cup Final and the
Eurovision song contest the rmt has
rejected the latest payoffer from the
Rel delivery group and has announced a
walkout at 14 train operators to
coincide with Eurovision in Liverpool on
the 13th of May meanwhile train drivers
from the aslef union will strike on
three more days including the cup final
at Wembley on the 3rd of June
initial data suggests Spain has
experienced its hottest April day on
record temperatures at Cordoba airport
reached 38.7 degrees Celsius today it's
forecast to get even hotter though with
40 degrees expected in some areas by the
weekend
and in the last half an hour Buckingham
Palace has announced who's going to be
performing ceremonial roles at the Kings
coronation at Westminster Abbey among
those playing an official part during
the service next weekend will be the
House of Commons leader Penny mordant
who will carry the sword of state and
baroness follower Benjamin who will hold
the scepter with the dove
Now Jerry Springer the TV host whose
Brash talk show became cult viewing has
died at the age of 79 from fights on set
to screaming matches and a man who
married a horse he presided over some of
the wildest moments on daytime
television with his hit show which
spawned several imitations and was even
turned into an opera tributes have been
paid from across the entertainment
industry as our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone reports
he was the daytime TV pioneer
his show ran for a remarkable 27 years
thank you welcome to the show format
that was simple
it was hardly wholesome a very angry
person at times deeply uncomfortable to
watch The Jerry Springer Show begins and
yet people did in their Millions
Jerry Springer was the talk show host
who didn't do much talking
sleeping with my man the show's success
his success was in other people's
dysfunction the struggles of his willing
guests
matter though you know we got kids
together a format he defended just
regular folks of no Fame little if any
wealth and very little influence folks
just taking a moment which they rarely
have ever get to let the world know
something about what they are thinking
or feeling or doing and so far from
being exploitative it was he said
Rebellion against the elite you don't
have to be born rich to make it it
wasn't always like that though in the
early years before the producers
realized what got the really big ratings
there was a more tender quality to his
shows you are going to meet your
daughter Sandy who you have not seen in
35 years
there's no questioning his influence
globally
in the UK the Springer format was
adapted Britain got Trisha she and he
became close friends
he couldn't be
life he was just like
I mean really sweet and he didn't take
himself too seriously but he was so kind
Jerry Springer's life had a remarkable
Arc born here in the London Underground
in 1944 his parents Sheltering from the
blitz above they were both German Jewish
refugees both his grandparents died in
Nazi camps immigration to America came
in 1950 where his eye was drawn to
politics after an unsuccessful bid for
Congress and to be governor of Ohio he
became the popular Progressive Mayor of
Cincinnati thank you thank you for
letting the son of refugees of Nazi
Germany Make It in America reflecting on
his life a family spokesperson said he's
Irreplaceable and his loss hurts
immensely but memories of his intellect
heart and humor will live on till next
time take care of yourself and each
other the catchphrase of a man who was a
central part of America's complicated
cultural fabric Mark Stone Sky News in
Washington